all right guys moving on we are
committed to stopping the stigma
surrounding mental health and taking the
shame and blame
out of discussing mental illness nearly
half of americans say
they are feeling stressed during the
coronavirus crisis that's according to a
recent study
now more people are turning to
meditation apps like
headspace space to cope with more than
66 million users 66 million
headspace is considered a leader in
mindfulness the company is now offering
get this
free one-year subscriptions to all
unemployed americans
co-founder andy put a comb voices many
uh voices many of the meditations rather
and he joins us now to voice his
perspective on why this
app can be so beneficial to people who
have lost their job andy good morning
uh before we get into the the the gift
uh and the benefits for unemployed
people let's talk just generally
why might meditation be something to
help at this particular moment
yeah i think morning tony i think for a
lot of people as you say they're feeling
very stressed
very anxious and we know through the the
scientific research around mindfulness
that that it can really help to decrease
those those things in our life
so i think now more than ever kind of we
need those tools i think it's not just
the physical
um sort of difficulties that many people
are going through but also the
sort of mental health challenges as well
yeah it's a wonderful program you're
offering now
to people who have lost their jobs but
you know the counter perspective here is
i mean if you're out of work you're
watching your bank account dwindle
you can't meditate your way back to
solvency you can't meditate your way
back to full employment so
how does it help a person in that
particular crisis
yeah and i think that really kind of
comes to the essence of meditation look
it's not going to change it's not going
to get you your job back
but what it can do is help you cope with
that process so it can help you
cope with the shock of losing your job
it can help cope with the anxiety of the
implications of what that might mean in
your life and to your family
and it can help rebuild confidence and
sort of finding a
clear sense of purpose as you go back
out and look for work so it's more about
how do we build up our inner resilience
to cope with what's going on in our life
rather than necessarily sort of changing
what's happening in our life
no andy there are people out there and
they're people watching right now they
probably just tried to leave the room
come back this question's for you
uh who think i'm just not the kind of
person who meditates i'm not a
meditation type person
what do you say to that individual in
particular
i would say that as human beings we
share many things and
one of we all struggle with our mind at
times and we all need a way to cope
with those struggles meditation is a
scientifically proven way
of coping with those struggles so even
if you think this isn't something for
you i always say to people
if you think it's not for you experiment
prove to yourself that it's not for you
try it
for five minutes a day for ten days and
see if it makes a difference or not
if you get to the end of the 10 days
it's made no difference okay you've
proven yourself that you're right
but maybe you might be surprised we
often see that the benefits of
meditation
although it's not a quick fix the
benefits of meditation have felt very
very early on
and the science suggests that it's less
about duration and how long we sit for
and it's more about frequency
so showing up for just a few minutes a
day can make a really big difference
well then if people who want to start
what should they know about showing up
to meditate that first time what should
their expectations be how do they get
started
yeah so look i i think there's three
things that spring to mind the first one
is
think of this a little bit like physical
exercise so we wouldn't just go out for
one run and expect it to be done and
over with
we'd sort of think about this as doing
it on a regular basis
same is true for training the mind same
time same place i think is a really
useful way to think about this
try and tie it to something that you
already do in the day so
it might be shower and meditate or
breakfast and meditate but kind of
making sure that you have
yeah like a regular a regular cadence
too and then the third thing is
and there's actually this feature on the
app is find a body
find a friend or a family member that
you can do this with that you can
support each other
on this journey it's not always easy to
sit with ourselves especially when we're
feeling very stressed very anxious very
you know upset in some way so so knowing
that we've got someone else there
to help us along the way is really
important and helpful
all right andy putty comb co-founder of
headspace and speaking of finding a
buddy andy is going to find a buddy of
mine later today to do a guided
meditation
with our very own vlad duttier it's
going to be on instagram live you check
that out
uh all you're going to do is head over
to the cbs this morning instagram page
to take part it's a great way to begin
if you haven't been meditating already i
haven't i might try